[MUSIC PLAYING]
KIM GORSUCH: Weeva is a place
to tell your stories online,
together with other people.
And then what we do is we
help you preserve them,
so you can keep them
in a book form forever.
We just finished a birthday
book for a 21-year-old boy.
And I was thinking,
well, we didn't really
design this for 21-year-olds,
and we definitely
didn't design it for boys.
And yet his family and
his friends came in,
and they wrote these beautiful
stories-- three, four,
five paragraphs long.
They put in the pictures
that they loved best.
They took pictures of
things that he'd made.
And the book is beautiful.
And he was as deeply
touched, at 21,
as we've seen with our couples
who are more in their 70's.
It occurred to me being
in four hospitals in a row
and watching so many
people who are critically
ill and basically by
themselves, that there
had to be a better
way for people
to provide the emotional support
that pulls people through that.
And so Weeva lets you contribute
memories and stories no matter
where you are in the world, no
matter how much time you have,
and no matter what
your skill level.
Just write a story about what
this person means to you,
and that all by itself
gives emotional support.
And it matters enormously.